peu
[Applaudissements]
le ministre des finances monsieur bond
gartner est allé tout spécialement à
moscou à la tête d'une importante
délégation pour inaugurer l'exposition
france ex pendant un mois les moscovites
pourront voir de près les 1000 aspects
de la france d'aujourd'hui un pays qui
n'est en dépit de certains avis ni des
cas d'un nid empêtré dans des
contradictions fatale
en l'absence de monsieur coach of madame
kucera fut la première visiteuse en
compagnie de quelques membres de sa
famille et de plusieurs personnalités
soviets
si le coeur artificiel la maquette
animée du réacteur g2 de marcoule et la
soucoupe sous-marine du commandant
cousteau sont les premiers pôles
d'intérêt de ces quarante mille mètres
carrés d'espacés couverts des
présentations de la mode française elle
déchaîne la curiosité et si cette vaste
entreprise de relations publiques est
l'objet de certaines critiques de la
presse soviétique
on ne pourra pas dire en tout cas que le
public l'a volontairement bouté à la
veille du débat de nu il n'y a pas eu de
nouvelles batailles de bizet les à
l'appel de monsieur bourguiba la tunisie
manifestent à tunis même s'est déroulée
la principale des manifestations
organisées par le gouvernement tunisien
et le néo destour pour redonner du
relief à la sphère qui s'estompe est un
peu derrière l'actualité vernis noir
une foule bardé de drapeaux et de
banderoles à défiler jusqu'à l'immeuble
du néo destour pourriat clamé le
président bourguiba
réduite au débat onusien auquel la
france ne prend aucune part
trois jours durant la capitale du gabon
qui porte le nom éloquent de libreville
a fait du premier anniversaire de son
indépendance sa première fête nationale
avec la délégation française présidée
par monsieur jacquinot près de quarante
délégations étrangères étaient plus
manifester leur sympathie aux jeunes est
à
la plus importante des cérémonies
devaient faire défiler devant monsieur
léon m'ba président de la république
gabonaise avec la jeune armée du nouvel
état souverain
les enfants des écoles et les groupes
sportifs
non
à la suite les chars des activités
sociales les groupes folkloriques
le tout au milieu d'un enthousiasme
sympathique qui donnait à ces festivités
l'air bonenfant d'une fête familiale
partout dans les rues des groupes animés
restituer le climat exubérant et coloré
du gabon traditionnel ce gabon qui à
travers les avatars de la vie n'a jamais
connu de différends entre africains et
européens et où le mât pas honte
d'avouer son affection pour la france
le plus épais mystère plane sur l'ancien
et belle résidence du cardinal de
vendôme à aix en provence où s'étaient
ouvertes l'exposition cézanne huit
tableaux ci sont volatilisés sans qu'on
sache ni comment ni pourquoi
comment la conservatrice qui dormaient
dans le pavillon et les agents de garde
seule demande toujours en escaladant la
façade et en atteignant une fenêtre par
la corniche peut-être deal enquête
[Musique]
pourquoi cette question ce sont les
visiteurs qui cela pose en contemplant
la place vide de la nature morte au
crâne
on s'imagine mal en effet qui puisse
exister une possibilité de monnayer des
toiles aussi célèbre que les joueurs de
cartes alors alors on interroge
longuement le mur vip shell mont mercure
en vendée a été également le témoin d'un
vol mais le plus honnête du monde
un hélicoptère a été un saint michel de
11 100 kg à prendre son essor vers le
clocher de l'église dont l'avait attiré
voici quelques années pour réparer des
blessures dues à une tempête trop
violent
il n'a fallu que deux jours pour mener
la faire à son terme alors que la même
opération avait nécessité quatre mois en
comme quoi l'hélicoptère fait bon ménage
avec les angles
berlin que partageaient une ligne
officielle mais idéal vient de voir
tomber entre ces deux zones le rideau de
fer
ce natale à berlin s'est éveillé au
bruit des marteaux-piqueurs qui trouait
l'astral
dans la nuit le gouvernement de bangkok
pour enrayer l'hémorragie des
populations vers l'allemagne de l'ouest
qui en dix ans lui avait enlevé deux
millions d'âmes avait décrété la
fermeture des communications entre les
deux zones et sur 40 km de longueur
ces 40 km par lesquels on pouvait encore
choisir la liberté la barrière
s'établissait rues barrées bombard et
métro arrêtée
il ne restait sur ses 40 km que 18
points de passage le contrôle était
sévère l'allemagne de l'est ce
cadenassait
[Applaudissements]
m
le maire de berlin ouest monsieur willy
bram était venu se rendre compte par
lui-même de l'herméticité du système que
seuls des harnais une vingtaine de
transfuges parvenait à traverser chaque
jour ils pouvaient voir la porte de
brandebourg symbole de la séparation des
deux berlin les chars des vopos prendre
position un authentique rideau de fer il
allait maintenant l'allemagne de l'est
les commandements alliés avaient
naturellement réagi immédiatement en
protestante auprès des autorités
soviétiques et en assurant le maire de
berlin monsieur willy-brandt de leur
soutien est venu de washington le vice
président des états unis monsieur lyndon
johnson assure est à la foule berlinoise
les etats unis connaissent leur
engagement et sont décidés à accomplir
tous leurs devoirs
je leur présentais le général le sus
clair l'homme du pont aérien des heures
troubles de 1948 qui venait de réclamer
son poste à berlin en même temps renfort
symbolique sans doute mais significatif
15 cents soldats américains avec 250
véhicules avaient franchi la frontière
et ouvrant sans encombre les 150 km du
couloir routier de prince vicat perd
l'un faisait leur entrée aux
acclamations de la foule
les derniers groupes de réfugiés irait
grossir les rangs de ceux dont la fuite
était pour le gouvernement ou le riche
une sorte de condamnation berlin a
maintenant été coupée en deux
sans fissures il y aurait tous les jours
du côté de l'est des groupes immobile
devant les barbelés mais la police de
l'est et là elle a l'oeil sur ces groupe
d'allemands en quête d'espoir par dessus
ces barrières deux mondes se regardent
et attendent le coeur serré
championnats d'europe de ski nautique à
bagnols à saint espagne championnat de
très haute qualité vous n'avez jamais vu
mieux
les skieurs français ont été des maîtres
de cette compétition deux gagnants
individuel jean marie muller et béatrice
martelly et la victoire tariq
quand on en arrive à cette perfection ce
n'est plus du sport mais de là
blinken a lors des championnats
d'allemagne de plantes malades de quoi
vous couper le souffle et la parole de
surcroît ce merveilleux petit balai nous
le devons à la fantaisie de l'opérateur
de 100 langues parlées la caméra
un plongeon de haut-vol succèdent les
figures féminines au tremplin
là encore nous sommes proches de la
perfection
oh
à
avec un tel trio de championne les
allemands peuvent s'envisager les
futures rencontres internationales avec
beaucoup de sérénité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]